Se ha demostrado
que hace falta al menos un millón de veces la masa del Sol en una zona densa,
para que se puedan formar estrellas.
Y sin materia oscura, nunca hay suficiente materia en un punto.
Aquí vemos dos universos, uno junto al otro.
En uno de ellos, las condiciones se vuelven densas muy rápido.
En ese universo, es muy probable que se formen galaxias.
En el otro universo,
las pequeñas masas que se forman se mantienen muy reducidas.
No ocurre gran cosa.
En ese universo, no llegaría a formarse nuestra galaxia ni ninguna otra galaxia.
No se formarían la Vía Láctea ni el Sol; no surgiríamos nosotros.
No existiríamos en ese universo.
Entonces, esta materia extraña, la materia oscura,
es gran parte de la masa del universo,
nos atraviesa ahora mismo, no estaríamos aquí sin ella.
¿Qué es?
Bueno, no tenemos ni idea.
Pero tenemos un montón de conjeturas fundamentadas,
y muchas ideas sobre cómo averiguar más.
La mayoría de los físicos piensan que la materia oscura es una partícula,
similar en cierto modo a las partículas subatómicas que conocemos,
como los protones, neutrones y electrones.
Sea lo que sea,
se comporta de un modo muy similar con respecto a la gravedad.
Pero no emite ni absorbe luz
y atraviesa la materia común como si ni siquiera estuviera allí.
Nos gustaría saber qué tipo de partícula es.
Por ejemplo, ¿cuánto pesa?
¿Ocurre algo si interactúa con la materia común?
Los físicos tienen muchas buenas ideas sobre lo que podría ser,
tienen mucha imaginación.
Pero es un tema difícil, son ideas de muy amplio espectro.
Podría ser tan pequeña como las partículas subatómicas más diminutas,
o podría ser tan grande como la masa de 100 Soles.
¿Cómo averiguamos qué es?
Los físicos y astrónomos tienen varios modos de detectar materia oscura.
Una de las cosas que estamos haciendo
es instalar detectores sensibles en minas subterráneas profundas,
con la esperanza de que una partícula de materia oscura,
que nos atraviesa a nosotros y a la Tierra,
colisione con un material más denso y deje algún rastro de su paso.
Buscamos materia oscura en el firmamento
con la esperanza de que las partículas de materia oscura colapsen
y generen luz de alta energía
que podríamos detectar con telescopios especiales de rayos gamma.
Tratamos incluso de crear materia oscura aquí en la Tierra:
fusionamos partículas y observamos lo que sucede,
con el uso del Gran Colisionador de Hadrones en Suiza.
Hasta el momento,
estos experimentos nos han hecho entender lo que la materia oscura no es,
si bien, no lo que es.
Había muy buenas ideas sobre lo que la materia oscura podría ser
que estos experimentos demostrarían, pero de momento no ha sido posible.
Debemos seguir buscando y estudiando más a fondo.
Otra forma de lograr entender qué es la materia oscura
es el estudio de las galaxias.
Ya hemos hablado de cómo nuestra galaxia y muchas otras galaxias
ni siquiera existirían sin la materia oscura.
Esos modelos también predicen muchas otras cosas sobre las galaxias:
cuál es su distribución en el universo,
cómo se mueven, cómo evolucionan en el tiempo.
Y podemos probar esas predicciones con observaciones del firmamento.
Les voy a poner dos ejemplos
del tipo de mediciones que podemos hacer con las galaxias.
El primero es que podemos hacer mapas del universo con galaxias.
Formo parte de un proyecto llamado "Dark Energy Survey",
que ha elaborado el mayor mapa del universo hasta ahora.
Medimos la ubicación y forma de 100 millones de galaxias
en una octava parte del firmamento.
Este mapa nos muestra toda la materia en esa zona del firmamento,
que se calcula por la luz distorsionada de esos 100 millones de galaxias.
La luz distorsionada por toda la materia entre esas galaxias y nosotros.
La gravedad de la materia es tan fuerte que desvía el trayecto de la luz.
Y nos da esta imagen.
Este tipo de mapas nos indican cuánta materia oscura hay;
también indican dónde está y cómo cambia en el tiempo.
Intentamos averiguar de qué está hecho el universo a una gran escala.
Resulta que las galaxias más pequeñas del universo
nos dan algunas de las mejores pistas.
¿Y eso por qué?
Estos son dos ejemplos de universos simulados
con dos tipos distintos de materia oscura.
Ambas imágenes muestran una zona en una galaxia como la Vía Láctea.
Puede verse una gran cantidad de otro material a su alrededor,
pequeñas acumulaciones.
En la imagen de la derecha,
las partículas de materia oscura se mueven más despacio que en la de la izquierda.
Si las partículas de materia oscura se mueven de forma acelerada,
la gravedad en los pequeños cúmulos no es lo bastante fuerte
como para ralentizar las partículas aceleradas.
Y siguen en movimiento.
Nunca colapsan en pequeños cúmulos.
Por tanto, se obtienen menos cúmulos que en el universo de la derecha.
Sin esos pequeños cúmulos, se obtienen menos galaxias enanas
Al observar el cielo austral,
se pueden apreciar dos de estas galaxias enanas,
las galaxias enanas más grandes que orbitan nuestra Vía Láctea:
la Gran Nube de Magallanes y la Pequeña Nube de Magallanes.
En los últimos años, hemos detectado muchas galaxias aún más pequeñas.
Este es un ejemplo de una de ellas,
detectada con el mismo estudio que usamos para hacer mapas del universo.
De entre estas galaxias realmente pequeñas,
algunas de ellas son sumamente pequeñas.
Algunas tienen tan solo unos pocos cientos de estrellas,
comparadas con los miles de millones de estrellas de nuestra Vía Láctea.
Eso hace muy difícil encontrarlas.
Pero en la última década,
hemos encontrado muchas más.
Ya conocemos 60 galaxias enanas que orbitan nuestra Vía Láctea.
Y estas enanas aportan muchas pistas sobre la materia oscura.
Porque la mera existencia de estas galaxias
indica que la materia oscura no debe moverse muy rápido,
y no debe de ocurrir gran cosa cuando se encuentra con la materia común.
En los próximos años, vamos a hacer mapas mucho más precisos del firmamento.
Y eso ayudará a refinar nuestras simulaciones del universo en su conjunto
y de toda la galaxia.
Los físicos también están llevando a cabo nuevos experimentos más precisos
para intentar detectar algún signo de materia oscura en sus laboratorios.
La materia oscura todavía es un gran misterio.
Pero es un momento muy interesante para trabajar en ello.
Tenemos pruebas muy claras de que existe,
a escala de las galaxias más pequeñas y a escala del universo en conjunto.
¿Llegaremos a encontrarla y a saber qué es?
No tengo ni idea.
Pero será muy interesante averiguarlo.
Tenemos muchas posibilidades de descubrirlo,
y sin duda averiguaremos más sobre lo que hace y lo que no hace.
Aunque no encontremos esa partícula en breve,
espero haberlos convencido
de que es un misterio que está muy cerca de casa.
La búsqueda de la materia oscura
podría ser la clave para una nueva comprensión de la física
y de nuestro lugar en el universo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)